hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm Tara Erickson Tara Erickson is a
woman a yeah B comedian if you're a
female comedian you have to use the
preface of female female got to
everyone's like wow you're a woman and
funny weird what a foreign concept you
know and three unpopular loud and likes
to make jokes that's right oh let's do
this thing
what are we doing here today great we're
gonna do a try not to laugh challenge ya
know I'm talking right now
quick validation for it for the voice
Joe Swanson about us are you just trying
to do another voice just do it a voice
cried a voice she does that doing the
try not to laugh is the perfect chance
to do it to have some moments for tears
now I'm making a lot of noise that's why
I like to do that one time where I'm
like exemption you might not speak for
just like a hot reminder Tara no
laughing got it and you cannot smile
either there cuz that's cheating that's
hard
well now I wanted the comedian's
instincts to rebell go against the grain
it's true I'm really ready though
headphones on Tara me me me me me me me
me me I gotta warm up Wow oh okay I feel
like I'm ready let's do it
mundo dos tres don't laugh think of
something sad think of something sad
think of them something sad okay puppies
dying great go
[Music]
sure thought they were coming after us
yes greenbook just won best sessions
death is so truly a Griffin Christmas
featuring such standards as and who
could forget everyone's favorite happy
merry Christmas everyone
oh my god those are Cheerios right maybe
time for me to get a job yeah too bad
you always blow it in the interview so
Peter where do you see yourself in five
years
don't sit with your wife don't see doing
your wife don't say doing your wife jr.
son
they told Peter to stay away from the
wolf but he didn't listen to them Jesus
Oh amen sometimes things have seen the
most dangerous turned out to be the most
fun yes sir that was a good day young
Peter
[Music]
are you a pedophile build a new
settlement we'll have a happy new life
and we'll have equal rights for all
except blacks Asians Hispanics Jews gays
women Muslims everybody is not a white
man
and I mean white one so no Italians no
polish just people from Ireland England
and strive but only certain parts of
struggling an island just full-blooded
whites no you know what
not even once nobody gets anywhere dad
what are we doing here Chris I'm gonna
show you how to stand up to a boy but
first I'm gonna show you how when I pull
the drawstrings on my sweatshirt and
spit out a candy bar I can't wash myself
know anybody with a pair of strong youth
hands to help me in and out of the tub
Oh Nance what's the problem
Thanksgivings exhausting you know what
she could use a little sip of that I
invented monster energy drink
news
[Music]
[Music]
yes look an 8 foot biscuit
let me just dump the turkey once I know
I can jam it that's not a regulation
rent okay you know what I'm in charge of
the turkey you're trying just hang on
yes now make a noise it's a hybrid trust
me it's on
Oh No
[Music]
[Music]
Oh what are these always cut off so
abruptly the second to last one action
reminds me of a dream I had last night
what was that my girlfriend Olivia naira
I was showing her she's from Colorado so
in my dream I was showing her more parts
of California and we were driving around
and we went down this road that was like
like a straight drop it was terrifying I
was like right all right
North Hollywood's nuts and then it was
like raining a little bit and we're on
this like wide-open row I got a freeway
or something the ground is broke and
then we went underwater when you're
dreaming you're not aware you're
dreaming I thought this was real I
immediately went I gotta save my
girlfriend normally my dreams if I'm
gonna fight or something I become very
weak it's like this weird fear I have
where like if someone's about to hit me
I just can't move but in this dream I
had to I was able to like take off the
seat belt and pull her out of the water
I felt like I'm a romantic hero and I
woke up I told her like you won't
believe the dream and I just saved your
ass that's exactly the words you say
save your ass you better be grateful for
the man who loves you
I gotta go brush my teeth by the way
[ __ ] love ya I never done anything
miRs that but I'm a hero in your eyes
now I have dreams where I can't move
like at all not not just easy I do
something and then sometimes when I'm
like half awake and I still can't move
it's called sleep paralysis it's
terrifying see it even in the corners
[Music]
maybe that's why I have so many issues
Olivia said I surprise you like a
neurologist or something because I have
nightmares for years every night is a
nightmare
oh really never have like oh that's
terrible good dream so I'm just waking
up cuz I'm having something that usually
what wakes me up is guys if he going
alright double that training I'm going
even though I save my girlfriend it's
still a nightmare we're trapping under
water and that's not normal
yeah so my repressed memories or
something every night that is not yeah
way I don't know what it is it's been
that way for years my whole life I think
actually where are these good dreams
everyone talks about the nightmare
suffer I'm a nightmare sufferer but hey
Matt's a lot of great ideas come from
tacos love it so that was my favorite
Club so yeah I feel like in LA it's not
as common now like if I go to a carnival
usually them you know the Mexican food
is used presumably Mexican people or
cooking or like Filipino booths that my
mom goes to it are at our carnivals we
have a carnival by the way same generals
these guys to visit us once a year April
that's sure like a lot of places even
but our restaurants even if I go to an
Asian restaurant and I just see a bunch
of why people cooking the food well I
leave no has my dad yes that's why it's
kind of weird I'm gonna have this white
band yeah we don't really add that
problem as much here in Ellen no but I
imagine like other parts of America are
you probably 10% people are that race
yeah it's kind of I would want they're
literally using taco mags out of a bag
and mixing it up with like ground beef
from Kroger for the Stewie one yes Joey
one monster he that's all Gregory she
lives off a dream bang oh and he drinks
bang I'm sorry I thought it was monster
he drinks bad never gonna get any drinks
bang nap monster its bang Olivia got me
in a bang and then now whenever I have
the Instagram app I noticed a lot of
Instagram models are always every time I
see one of my feet it's a it's a big
promotion oh they're drinking bang
that's how it Johnson takes packs just
in case bangs
to use that mmm hi my name is Tara
Eriksson I can be our next paying
influencer a [ __ ] pretend they're so
Spang bang bang hey those half-naked
female fitness models ha ha ha ha ha
they're an inspiration and they are not
sex objects on Instagram though I love
them too I wish I had their bodies to be
honest I'm being honest I'm just trying
to be a bang model I'm trying really
hard it's never gonna work out as up I'm
do you laugh cry cuz I wouldn't be a
positive influence or I want to be
honest at the same time I can't tell
where the library sardian where it
starts and begin oh gosh
ok hey making fun of them cuz you want
to actually be one ok I'm not sure but
they're great people they work hard
yeah they do lot harder than me you know
there's always so many angles you can
tell you of your ass and they've managed
to make that a consistent they may go
think rotate one quarter of a centimeter
[Laughter]
grab photographers rotate to one listen
guys before I wrap this up I would like
to have a patient the day shot so a man
named Taylor Bentley here's the deal
okay we gave a shout out to him on a
video for the twilight zone that video
got blocked after 3,000 views those
3,000 views came fast I was like oh BAM
successful video we gave a lot of
commentary on that that's up on patreon
but it supposed to be a YouTube channel
it's further rewards here so roll that
clip with John and I Taylor I want you
to know my friend I know the last couple
times of Shia talked about how you kind
of ignore me because now you have a new
hot girlfriend welcome to the twilight
zone [ __ ] Oh
because now I'm your new girlfriend
that's right and this girl loves to be
eaten I was gonna say what girl doesn't
but they are
there are some who are very opposed
against it and I'm not one of those
girls Taylor yeah I like to be treated
with flowers I will not change my facial
hair you'll have to deal with it I'm
just a girl who's unfortunately has this
and I've embraced it whoever that girl
is she's now me in this reality where
she is hosting the real rejects yeah so
in some ways the way they have leveled
up if you really loved her
you would want what's best for her yeah
and what better way than to give her a
YouTube channel yeah her own living you
know season a nobility and now I'm stuck
with you and I resent you for being a
terrible boyfriend of me because you
don't see a woman with you there I do
and that's why we have such a good
friendship I know we have a Dinah Fitz
I respect you just totally cancel out
each other I just want her Taylor's
feelings but you know what I mean yeah
Taylor we love you I don't know yeah but
I love your - I like the last name it's
Bentley after a nice car subscribe to
the rejects
it's a notification about me to a more
interesting than these guys they know
where to come on man you could ride me
too even these guys through his
controller